dear D just why is it that all these
entries are about guys I mean what's the
big deal I think my 11 year old self
knew I was gay
[Music]
I fell under the nerd category I still
fit in that category but I've learned to
embrace it I was boy crazy
I was so more crazy not much has changed
I was heavily involved with theater and
chorus was very overachieving when it
came to the Performing Arts that's all I
cared about is trying to be cool to my
older cousins this kind of loser a nerd
I had a few friends but then I was also
very weird I was weird before weird was
like a thing that people like to do to
brand themselves oh man this summer I
met the cutest Swedish boy we played
soccer together walked in the rain
together dear diary
forget about Andy and Nick how about
Benj he is so fine how is it that
Swedish boys are so much hotter than
gross American public benches so hot
he's Korean and Norwegian with lawn tips
I hate my non-existent dating life so
much why won't Claire talk to me like
why I basically did her whole entire lab
report for her come on Claire that's so
savage of you I really want to lead in
The Wizard of Oz but there's just two
things in my way Bratz n and s s is such
a brat and she sucks
I pray to God she doesn't get Dorothy I
want Wicked Witch of the West Cowardly
Lion scarecrow or Tin Man guess what I
got cast as Dorothy July 18 2001 today I
thought I'd tell you about Zack two
words mhm major howdy this girl I have
no interest in asked to be my date to
the 8th grade formal but all I want to
do is take Claire I've never felt this
way about anyone before I'm totally in
love with her does she loves me I don't
know I don't know why I thought a plural
was a good idea like I'm like 13 14 by
this time March 22nd 1988 you'll never
believe this all the popular kids
running for class president got beaten
by and eerie bold this was huge because
Andy he wore bright orange shoes and his
motto was vote for the Schmo with the
shoes that glow and he won and it was a
great victory for nerds everywhere thank
you Andy
thank you and did I mention
he's from London England yeah his accent
makes him ten times hotter than he
already is
I had my first sip of beer today it
tasted like absolute ass the dance was
so fun the whole time we were dancing we
were staring into each other's eyes I
hate this I hate beer I hate girls I
hate Christmas only Radiohead gets me I
think it's so funny to have a diary and
an cathartic you know even when I was 11
this was really important for me to
write yeah I'm never gonna stop keeping
Diaries and I'm so happy that I have
these no matter how freakin embarrassing
they are I would tell myself the things
that make you seem weird now will
continue to make you seem weird but as
you get older that's kind of cool the
rest is still unwritten I'm under so
much stress of who I'm taking eighth
grade formal I feel like I'm the
president of all of the states
I mean eighth grade for both bigger than
seed here prep time to get info from
Radiohead